today there are more than 500 million
people in Europe how can we insure them
a stable supply of healthy safe and
affordable food now and in the future
the answer lies with our farmers
essential to our economy and our society
there are more than 12 million full-time
farmers in the EU and 46 million people
involved in farming and the agri-food
sectors but the farming business is at
the mercy of economic and weather
conditions beyond farmers control which
is why Europe supports it through its
common agricultural policy or cap
this provides a safety net for Europe's
many different kinds of farmers and
farming practices so they can produce
enough food over time the policy has
changed its newest reform makes the cab
greener fairer and more efficient it
supports farmers incomes to ensure that
they can continue to produce food
throughout the EU and to help them
deliver public benefits
it also offers new resources to farmers
to strengthen their position in the food
supply chain
Europe is known throughout the world for
the quality and diversity of its food
and culinary traditions with the cap
europe's farmers can ensure an abundant
variety of quality european products
today tomorrow and for future
generations europe's common agricultural
policy taking care of our roots
you